Look simple,
doesn't it?
When you're dealing with a master of
slight of hand,
like my partner teller,
even the simplest activity may be a
complex deception.
Tell number fascinated by how stupid
magic is.
That magic is going through all these
elaborate machinations to make something
look one way that's really another and
instruct us is really funny to do a
magic trick that accomplished reality.
Tell her needs nothing but a pencil,
one lit cigarette and a flashlight.
Let's watch that original routine again.
But this time from the other side and we
went through many,
many things.
We were going to originally do it with
cooking or something like that,
but after weeks of trying to write this
bit,
we came up with the idea of how about
uh,
taking out a cigarette,
lighting it,
putting a cigarette out and then pulling
out another cigarette and lighting it.
How about if we did that trick exactly
like that with all accomplished by
trickery stuff you could do simply.
And that seemed to have such a,
um,
purely existential field to us,
uh,
going through incredibly complicated
machinations to get to a very simple end
simulates a line liner when the
flashlight was the,
let's take a red pencil and the cover of
misdirection from the flashlight.